hey I'm Greg I'm Greg I'm great - Greg
and Greg - are here with me today to do
a reaction review of another car three
trailer oh boy oh I think is the fourth
one called next generation Wendy Lee
it's a real name not Greg when you leave
from you might know from Collider and
she's also has her own Shannon explained
movie movie movie couple channels but
she does with her hobby stuff doesn't
mean yeah you look great
hi honey yeah hi I'm a joke John my
jealous let me know listen I you know my
I postponed on doing the reaction is a
because I've had many a camera problem
with the camera broken my on borrowing
Anita's right now which is actually
significantly nice yes thank you and you
I mean the star subscribe to her channel
thank her for our camera and B I figured
Wendy's coming by Sam I will say some
actual like worthwhile videos for her
make sure they get some views you know
that's about the views all about the
view has been algorithms the first
person requests this that I saw in the
comments matrix master 22 22 you notice
talking about bringing back the matrix
oh really
really how does she do it okay I think
it's funny where she'll face or
something hmm
we're gonna watch the shot at the car
Street
[Applause]
huh
[Music]
is better right
[Music]
writers oh man Master Carter
what about car hire
the worst color
hoarsely more horsepower let's be kind
of breaks my heart a little bit
they're really growing all clear and
hires all the little now
oh never be the racer he once were
you can't turn back the clock here
Wow can wind it up again
this is so the most interesting
marketing I've seen for a movie just
ever from a birthday oh yeah after your
birthday all right well here my first
thought yeah okay this keeps going back
to the marketing of this movie the first
trailer was like whoa yeah is terrifying
the second and third trailer have been
like a little more fun to keep going
back to this like next generation
Richard again in the new cars there's a
villain car like the one is ultimate
rival yeah this keeps in this whole
trailer was all about how cars are
faster and stronger it is the next
generation yeah yep in order to be
better and win races you got to be
faster in that this crazy yeah for
chronic [ __ ] and computer calculated
speed dial the message is going to be
about it doesn't matter what your gear
is like doesn't matter if you have the
best or the fastest what matters if you
have heart yeah heart is harder the real
horsepower
you know then Bheema thousand hearts
exactly right there and heart is a real
horse software yeah these trailers just
keep reminding me of like an easy action
movie kind of it I can't thinking of
like Rocky Balboa was Rocky for even
this reminder like rocky versus Drago
weird even enough that we gotta have
this serious like you're too old you
can't do it rock you know that he's
coming back any volume sure that it
happens already as umber switch yeah I
mean it seems like it's going for like
this eighties action vibe every trailer
is like an intense action movie but it's
kind of chugging anything like ours is a
clubbing music this time though well yes
it did sound like the like like the
fight scene in the club in collateral is
American with yeah this trailer has me
intrigued all these trailers have me
intrigued because I'm like you're really
going distinct with the tone that
yourself out of me the thing I keep
wondering about is like we saw those
little snippet from us letting other
characters yeah and that's the thing I
don't feel I got any idea about when it
comes to this I don't know what this
movie this bill is it
there was a third trailer that did show
how lightning McQueen you know like he
loses the race and then he's exactly
what we're talking about our tool we
can't do this and it is other car play
with Harvey MLP well right yeah yeah the
Hispanic one yeah obviously the Hispanic
one you could tell by her voice that's
not me being racist it's obvious exactly
my least favorite trailer out of olive
oil
yeah it's John has a good point because
it's been for trailers and none of them
are like I've just a full on trailer
which is no they're like promo teasers I
guess that would work better to it like
I don't mind that idea but I guess that
would work better for me if each one of
them was different and I feel like three
of them are pretty similar yeah you know
like everyone that's about lightening
feels like this is this time they showed
us slightly more footage edited kind of
the same way so it's all like oh intense
so like it like I said it does get me
interested but at the same time tired of
the marketing a little bit you think I
wish there get more creative and I'm
also like they got my attention in a way
that made me go okay I want to see what
you're doing and they haven't given me
anything else so now I'm like you still
want me to be excited but I don't know
if you're going to actually come through
with like an interesting idea I didn't
see cars to but I I don't know anybody
who had good thing sweating a lot of
cars - I love this so much that I never
thought and I like the first cars like I
like the first cars like I never saw him
I would be happy to see cars do
something cool again the first time I
saw one of these trailers I thought
maybe they're doing a marble thing where
they're at least going to marry it to a
different tone of a movie or different
genre of movies and taking it more to
like you know NASCAR that imagery like
that's cool the joke you may is like I
is this is gonna be about how hard is it
yeah and I yeah basically you know which
is good but I hope it's not just okay I
mean I'm still very much looking forward
to the film but I am ready like you
guys's book said I'm ready to see
something different in each trailer like
I am ready to not see Lenny McLean doing
those flips of blowing on seismic we
know something tragic happened you
showed us four times now yeah yeah they
[ __ ] shot it okay I got the oh [ __ ]
factor and you could even justify like
reminding us about I wanted like
downfall it's kind of like
while you know and I don't want to lose
that you know I go with this beer yeah
keep the momentum of excitement going
between six yeah I love you dude look
look it's the best damn good earlier
when she asked you update okay you
editing get anything kinda like what is
going on good right Jagger was like
women all right well why do you leave
going to be competing in the next movie
trivia showdown so I keep a lookout for
that really nah she we're trying to get
it going
oh so if you drive into real rejection
John's reason to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram he's a social media manager a
real reject bamboo on my house Wendy Lee
like we said earlier you can catch her
on the movie couple channel where it's
about a couple who likes movies super
relatable group all couples out there
and those who are single hoping to one
day have a significant other
that's what when you channel does for
people like me and she's also on
Collider so go check her out there and
we sometimes go uncle I yes he didn't
know we do when he was just talking
about you're gonna make sure she brings
us on the next movie talks to promote on
female presence position well yeah
because I yeah beautiful hair thank you
like you're here a lot my husband you
said Wong here city what was how long
like this one yeah I don't think I've
seen it yeah pictures I'll show you I
was going after this yeah I'll tell you
guys how it is
I'll react to it on your predict